voilà 50 ans on étit donc publié en
France L'Archipel du Goulag ou Alexandre
senicine révélait l'horreur et l'ampleur
du système concentrationnaire soviétique
au beau milieu des années 70 ce livre
vendu à plus de 10 millions
d'exemplaires de par le monde filffet
d'une bombe c'est ce que vient de nous
rappeler à l'instant ce documentaire
exclusif coécrit par Jean crépu et
Nicolas MTIC de quoi nous interroger
maintenant plus au-delà sur ce plateau
de débadoc sur ces remous déflagrations
provoqué à l'époque par le ce livre
historique venu ébranler les fondements
même du mythe révolutionnaire communiste
Jean crépu est avec nous bienvenue Jean
crépu vous êtes donc documentariste je
ramène ceux qui nous regardent à votre
filmographie 20 ans de de documentaire
ce documentaire est exclusif pour notre
chaîne mais il y a 15 ans vous en aviez
réalisé un autre qui s'intitulait
l'histoire secrète de l'archipel du
goulac qui a déjà fait l'objet d'une
émission d'badoc où il était question
de savoir comment il avait été possible
de sortir ce livre de le publier en
russe tout d'abord et puis ensuite chez
nous en France en
1974 il y a maintenant 50 ans Stéphane
Courtois est également avec nous
bienvenue vous êtes historien
spécialiste du communisme vous avez été
entre autres le coordinateur et le
préfacier du Livre noir du communisme
publié en 1997 c'était chez Robert
Lafond vos derniers livres s'intitule
histoire du Parti communiste Françis
publié au presse universitaire de France
et le Livre noir de Vladimir Poutine
coécrit cette fois avec l'historienne
Galia akckerman est disponible là encore
chez Robert Lafond ser Julie est
également avec nous bienvenue vous êtes
journaliste nous allons rappeler que
vous avez été l'un des
cofondateurs du quotidien Libération
c'était en 1973 et que vous avez dirigé
ce quotidien entre 1974 et 2006 avant de
devenir éditorialiste sur différents
médias euh Serge Julie juste avant qu'on
commence à entamer notre discussion
1974 euh vous êtes à la tête de
libération il y a j'imagine des
conférences de rédaction y a-t-il eu une
conférence de rédaction dont vous vous
souvenez justement à propos de la sortie
quand même la publication en française
L'Archipel du Goulag je peux faire comme
château brillant je peux inventer des
souvenirs mais euh ça ça me paraît
difficile non autrement dit non je non
je lu ajoute quand même quelque chose
euh se G signe a un avant genit si j'ose
dire qui nous a éveillé qui est une
journée d'Iv denisovic parce que le
goulag existe à partir de 1962 ouais on
parle de 73 parce que c'est l'événement
mais la quand il publie cette nouvelle
dans novmir avec l'autorisation de
krutchev qui intervient personnellement
pour que çappisse dans c'est la
révélation du Gou en revanche en 74 et
après 14 au cœur des années 70 vous avez
pas de de souvenir de discussion un peu
re au sein de la rédaction libération
personnel qui était euh j'éta j'ai fait
partie de l'Union des étudiants
communistes donc nous étions en bagarre
avec la direction du Parti communiste et
évidemment tous tous ces gestes tous ces
livres là étai évidemment brandis voilà
sans arrêt puisque le Parti communiste
avait cette particularité que connais
vous connaissez bien tous les deux c'est
le rapport du 20e congrès de crutchef
n'existait Pasir il n'existe qu'à partir
de 80 je crois on va y revenir on va y
revenir puis vous avez en commun tous
les deux d'avoir été maoistste à un
moment à la fin des années des années 60
quand on voit le le bilane de Mao
concernant les les droits de l'homme ça
ça ça en dit beaucoup peut-être sur ce
qui était la la perception de la gauche
française à l'époque de de de ces
régimes communistes Jean crépu je l'ai
dit donc donc 15 ans après avoir ré un
premier documentaire consacré à
l'archipel du goulac vous décidez de
nous livrer celui-là pourquoi oui parce
que sur ce premier film où on avait pu
recueillir le le ce qui a été la
dernière interview de sonine où
précisément il voulait revenir sur
L'Archipel du Goulag on a raconter cette
histoire jusqu'au moment où le livre est
publié toute cette histoire clandestine
ce passage rquambolesque digne de John
leCarré d'un microfilm et puis le film
s'arrêtait au moment où le livre est
publié et on s'était dit avec Nicolas
Miletic que ça ferait l'objet d'un
deuxième film c'est-à-dire ce qui allait
se passer et Dieu sait qu'il s'est passé
des choses au moment où le livre est
enfin publié enfin enfin c'est vrai que
ceine met longtemps il a un certain
nombre d'années où il écrit
difficilement dans cette clandestinité
et puis quand il donne l'ordre de
publier le livre parce que le livre a
été saisi par le KGB là c'est le séisme
c'est et qui va durer longtemps et donc
c'était cette histoire là qui en qui
était en fait la suite de notre premier
film on a mis 15 ans à à pouvoir
retourner notre notre manivelle mais
mais voilà on tenait beaucoup à à à
compléter d'une certaine façon ce qu'on
avait avec un témoignage important celui
de Natalia qui était la femme tout à
fait dans ce film qu'on avait rencontré
il y a il y a 15 ans et qui a bien voulu
revenir grâce à une équipe russe qui a
pu tourner puisque nous nous n'étions
pas c'était évid pas possible d'aller
tourner là-bas mais qui a pu elle aussi
témoigner le Parti communiste français
je vous ai promis d'y revenir c'est Juli
on y revient tout de suite avec un
premier extrait de ce documentaire ça
commence par une intervention de George
Marchet nous sommes à saint-toin devant
les les militants communistes après la
sortie de L'Archipel du Goulag dans ce
livre l'auteur russe évoque des faits
que le Parti communiste de l'Union
soviétique a lui-même dénoncé
publiquement il y a près de 20 ans et
auquel il a mis un terme en fait le
Parti communiste français à cette époque
n'a jamais rien condamné il faudra
attendre 1977 pour qu'il reconnaisse
l'existence du fameux rapport krutchev
présenté en
1956 au 20e congrès du Parti communiste
de l'Union soviétique ce rapport
dénonçait le culte de la personnalité de
Staline mais sans évoquer les crimes de
masse estimés à 15 ou 20 millions de
mort alors là Stéphane Courtois on a
envie de dire circuler il y a rien à
voir c'est la première réaction
officielle du parti communiste français
et j'ai eu très souvent ce type de
réaction y compris de la part de mes
chers collègues historiens communistes
hein parce que tant que les archives ne
se sont pas ouvertes on était confronté
à ce problème comment comment documenter
hein sérieusement sans discussion
possible ce que nous affirmion et alors
on disposait de beaucoup de témoignages
alors solienitsine bien entendu tout
l'archipel repose sur les témoignages et
nous en tant qu'historien des années 70-
80 et bien c'était les témoignages des
exomunistes de Tyon de gens comme ça et
à chaque fois nos chers collègues nous
disaient ah oui non mais ça on connaî ça
depuis longtemps ah mais non mais ça
mais comment euh vous avez des documents
vous n'avez pas de documents mais
comment osez-vous affirmer ceci ou cela
et tant qu'on tant qu'il y a pas eu les
Archiv on était coincé alors la chose
extraordinaire de solenitsin c'est que
avec ses centaines de témoignages il a
réussi à réconstituer mais
effectivement c'est toujours pareil il
faut croire il faut croire celui qui
transmet les témoignages à partir du
moment où les archives s'ouvrent il y a
plus de discussion possible on a les
ordres de Staline et cetera de Lénine
tout est là parce que ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est que les Soviétiques
archivaient tout ben c'est des gens
d'ordre c'est c'est des gens d'ordre mon
mon collègue Nicolas verte qui avait
fait le la la première partie du Livre
noir du communisme sur l'URS a qualifié
c la civilisation du rapport tout
remonté au sommet et tout était conservé
ce qui est extraordinaire et pour les
historiens c'est formidable et en
particulier pour l'association mémoriale
don dont on parle dans le documentaire
et 21 ans après le PCF n'avait toujours
pas reconnu le rapport kutchev euh
Maurice Torz qui était le le le numéro 1
du PCF à l'époque hein en 56 à l'époque
du 20e congrès du parti communist
soviétique disait un rapport euh qu'on
attribue à à Nikita kutchef dans dans le
documentaire vous allez voir derrière
l'épaule de marché un petit personnage
qui est Jacques Duclot on est en 1974 il
va mourir en 75 c'est le le dirigeant le
plus stalinien du Parti communiste
français il est au bureau politique
depuis
1931 on est en 1974 et c'est lui qui
tient tout c'est lui qui a fait désigner
marché pour succéder euh à à aval
descrochet qui était malade donc voilà
il a y a il y a une continuité
formidable du contrôle des Soviétiques
sur ce parti jacqu Duclos céit le
candidat du PCF en en 69 j'ai regardé
hein son score il avait réalisé un score
de
21,27 % voilà ce que nous dit ce
documentaire ser Julie c'est qu'on est
en
plein programme commun constitution du
programme commun c'est après juste après
le programme comm juste après entre
communiste et et socialiste
le Parti communiste français et le et le
parti dominant de la gauche française en
ce début des années 70 dominant qu'a
provoqué L'Archipel du Goulag au de
cette gauche de l'époque je le fais je
le fais court ça fait lire François
mitéran je crois que parmi les facteurs
qu'on fait élire François mitterin il y
a seul génine pourquoi parce que le PC
sort de
68 déjà contesté parce que 68 était une
contestation du Parti communiste avec
son score présidentiel de 69 il il se
refait la serise et il il est la partie
dominante de la gauche euh François
mitéran se présente euh en
644 à la présidentielle euh donc
derrière il y a toute la machinerie
programme commun tout ça et cetera
refonde du Parti socialiste et en gros
François mitteran
euh toute l'Europe de la
social-démocratie regarde François
mitéran comme un un zombie un zombie et
lui leur explique très simplement qu'il
va mettre le PC en dessous de 10 %. et
et en c'est ce qui va réaliser et il va
réaliser aidé par tout un tas de
facteurs parmi ces facteurs il y a 68
mais il y a surtout seul génitine et
c'est cette volonté de cannibaliser en
quelque sorte le le Parti communiste
français qui fera que du côté du Nouveau
Parti
socialiste avec sa tête franç mitteran
ça sera un peu le silence radio aussi où
il y aura quand même quand même un débat
au sein du Parti socialiste à l'époque
il y en aura très peu il y a il y a
évidemment l'idée c'est voilà maintenant
le les camp ça existe faut faut bien
avoir en tête que dans le parti
communiste comme à gauche comme à gauche
à la gauche non communiste c'est on est
face au gens communistes disant au
moment du procès Kravchenko ça n'existe
pas les camps soviétiques les camps
n'existent pas en Union soviétique et et
c'est répété de manière il y a des
procès avec David Rousset avec voilà et
tout ça est répété de manière bon c'est
un peu terrorisant c'est-à-dire moi
j'étis toujours frappé que dans ces deux
procès qu'on connaît bien qu'on a
épluché ces deux procès il y a personne
de la gauche non comm communiste qui
vient témoignerou les gens qui viennent
témoigner sont des étrangers sont des
Allemands
des la margarte
bberneman qui a a l'avantage d'avoir
connu à la fois le goulag soviétique et
ravensb donc qui était une expérience
très fine quoiin de on va voir un nouvel
extrait du documentaire Jean crépu parce
que la sortie de L'Archipel du Goulag
crée des remous au sein des
intellectuels français a défaut d'en
créer peut-être dans la gauche française
de
l'époque les deux jeunes intellectuels
les plus actifs dans la défense de ce
génine c'est André gluxman et Bernard
Henri leville Andr gluxman une très
belle formule à ce sujet il dit les
c'est un bon point de vue sur le
marxisme c'est-à-dire ça nous permet de
lire la la substantifique moelle du
marxisme
c'était pierre rigouot hein qui
s'exprimait dans dans dans cet extrait
parce que c'est ça le fond de l'affaire
en réalité et ça rejoint la la la phrase
citée par cet historien concernant André
gluxman on passe de l'idée selon
laquelle la révolution russe serait
sortie de ses railles à une vision où ça
sera elle-même porteuse du Goulag
autrement dit que cette réalité
concentrationnaire définie décrite dans
dans dans dans ce livre est
consubstantielle du communisme et c'est
là quand même
qui crée un fabuleux débat au sein de la
gauche là franaise de l'épou une
fracture un peu plus tôt dans le
documentaire on voit une prise de parole
de Boris yukov qui était député de la
Doua de de l'époque qui dit bien voilà
ce personnage de cicine est détestable
il est détestable surtout parce qu'il
met en cause l'énine il il met en cause
le le le le le le cœur même le fondateur
et ça et et jukov le dit et il le dit
d'une façon il arrive même pas à dire
compand de concentration il dit il fait
porter à Lénine la responsabilité des
camp ce qui est insupportable et et
voilà on parce que les premiers camp
c'est 1923 sur les îles Solovski c'est
pas très loin de la la Finlande
d'ailleurs et donc là cette remise en
cause là elle n'est pas supportable là
ce que c'est ça le fond de l'affaire non
attends attendez Stéphan courtoi
peut-être pour commencer le fond de
l'affaire le fond du débat qui a eu lieu
à l'époque il est là
non 1956 le fameux rapport secret def
que vous avez évoqué parce que dans ce
rapport secret krutchev tape sur Staline
et encore pour quelques petits crimes
concernant des dirigeants communistes il
ne parle pas des crimes de masse mais
s'il tape sur Staline c'est pour mieux
relégitimer le régime à travers Lénine
en disant voilà le grand homme c'est
Lénine qui se méfiait de lui qui se
méfiait de
stalineou mais c'est dans le rapport
dans le
rapport bien sûr hein donc on voit très
bien l'opération et cette opération
n'est pas du tout une opération
improvisé il y a eu des réunions du
Bureau politique on a maintenant les
archives où ils ont monté toute cette
affaire hein et le plus étonnant c'est
que kutchef avait demandé que les
services établissent un état des des
victimes et et alors les services ils
font leur ils font leur ils font leur
rapport en disant sous le zzar il y a eu
6350 condamnés à mort sous le sous le
sous le régime soviétique il y en a eu 1
million donc et au bureau politique les
plus jeunes qui qui qui n'ont pas été
proche de Staline parce que kutchef il
était très proche de Staline ils
connaissait l'individu mais les plus
jeunes qui avaient été promus après il
avitme d'ailleurs participé à certaines
cur il plus que
participé éouvert de sang des pieds à la
tête C chef hein mais les plus jeunes on
a les on a les sténogrammes disent mais
mais c'est le diable mais mais c'est
abominable ils ils sont euxê on est au
cœur du du dispositif ils sont
stupéfaits donc vous imaginez le le choc
que ça pu être pour toute la population
puis pour tous les communistes c'est
vraiment le pavé dans la vitrine alors
sur cette question fondamentale André
gluxman évidemment on parle aussi de de
Bernard Henry leville à l'époque qui
fait partie de et du côté des des
journalistes sont évidemment il y a Jean
Daniel Le Nouvel Observateur qui lui
prend très vite parti pour en faveur de
ceux qui défendent L'Archipel du Goulag
et de des tèes qu'il véhic il est gens
d'esprit hein ouais manaqueou qu'est-ce
qu'on peut dire de ce débat des des
nouveaux intell c'est comme ça qu'on les
app à l'époque les nouveaux philosophes
ou les nouveau philos philosoph allons
passons vite c'est c'est pas la
dimension philosophique mais c'est la la
question principale à la fois
solgénitine les nouveaux philosophes et
les archives ouais c'est quoi c'est le
totalitarisme d'un seul coup on découvre
que c'est un régime totalitaire ça
change tout ça change tout c'est plus
telle tendance du Parti communiste et
trotsk contre les les machins les les
les menchevies qu' on été non c'est le
totalitarisme c'est-à-dire c'est un
système qui a été décrit abondamment par
anaren par par tout un tas de
philosophes et en particulier par un un
petit noyau de la gauche française qui
est socialisme et barbarie oui bon qui a
fait hein le fort ou le fort quoi Daniel
le fort et évidemment les toute la bande
de socialisme et barbarie donc ça ça
fait tilte ça fait tilte évidemment pour
gluxman et et et ben h Levy et tous les
autres nouveaux philosophes mais ça fait
tilt y compris pour tous les les
néocommunistes ou les les les gens qui
sont intéressés à toutes ces questionsl
fait chez beaucoup de communistes qui
avaient d'ailleurs leur carte au PCF
dans les années 50 ou voilà voà c'est
intéressant parce que gluxman dans un
extrait qu' qu'on a retrouvé d'une
émission de télé assez extraordinaire où
ils sont tous autour de la table avec
che chez Clavel
gluxman persiste à dire mais L'Archipel
du Goulag ne se lit pas dans les
librairies de gauche pourquoi il
interpelle tout le monde autour de la
table et c'est c'est voilà il il ne
s'achète pas dans les libr de GAE non il
dit j'aimerais savoir pourquoi GL 5000
quand
même a un BL oui donc ça se lisait qu
gauche il y a un blocage il y a un
blocage qui effectivement vient sur
totalitarisme parce que dès qu'on parle
de totalitarisme automatiquement on part
dans la comparaison avec le nazisme et
évidemment pour des éminents
antifascistes que se proclam tous les
gens communistes d'extrême gauche et
cetera c'est quelque chose d'impensable
d'inimaginable cette comparaison vous y
êtes aventuré quelque part ah ben moi je
m'y suis aventuré mais on a eu
exactement les mêmes problèmes quand on
a publié le livre Livre noir du
communisme en 97 hein sur quoi a-t-on
été attaqué moi en particulier sur
totalitarisme donc la comparaison et
deuxièmement sur l'implication de Lénine
dans l'origine de toute cette affaire et
de tous ces crimes le problème c'est
qu'entre-temps et par rapport à
solienittin les archives souverins on
avait les documents de Lénine qui
n'avait jamais été publié dans Les
œuvres de Lénine parce que quand même
les œuvres de Lénine en français vous en
avez 40 volumes hein donc il y a de quoi
lire mais comme par hasard ça s'appelle
pas œuvre complète parce que justement
les les documents les plus
compromettants c'està-dire ceux où
Lénine dit trouvez des gens plus durs
pendez plus fusiller et cetera ah ben on
les avait mis sous le tapis ils sont
sortis après 91 et c'est pour ça que
Nicolas vert a pu les a pu les publier
dans le Livre Noir Le le plus étonnant
vous raconta quand même une petite
séance quand on préparait ce livre on
s'est réuni on était cinq principaux
auteursou et un jour vert a dit bon je
vais vous lire mon premier chapitre qui
concernait le début de cette affaire
1917 et cetera
et on mais on était quand il l'a lu et
où Lénine était mis en cause nommément
et complètement on l' a dit c'est pas
possible c'est impensable on ne peut pas
publier ça ENF nous-même on était
totalement choqué et là il s'est mis en
colère en disant mais c'est les archives
il en a Mar et cetera bon donc on a
capitulé bon et on l'a publié mais c'est
pour vous dire en 0 enfin on préparait
ça en 96 début 97 c'est pour vous dire à
quel point on était encore dans un un
climat
intellectuel imprégné et et où Lénine
restait une figure intouchable y compris
à droite compris à droite alors je v
citer un certain nombre de personnalités
qui ont défendu C L'Archipel du Goulag
des personnalités qui avaient d'ailleurs
rendu leur carte notamment du PCF en 56
après après évidemment l'affaire de
Budapeste Edgar Morin Jean davignot
Claude Roy François Furet voilà tous
ceux ont publié des choses notamment
dans le nouvel observateire peut-être
aussi d'ailleurs je ne sais pas dans
Libération oui ah oui beaucoup oui
dernier extrait du du film ça nous
rapproche de notre époque aujourd'hui
cette fois c'est c'est Raphaël
glusman fils bien sûr d'andr glusman qui
s'exprime et bien l'ennemi numéro 1 de
Poutine c'est mémorial l'ennemi numéro 1
de Poutine c'est ceux qui documentent
les crimes du Stalin
l'ennemi numéro 1 de Poutine c'est ceux
qui poursuivent l'œuvre de L'Archipel du
Goulag mémorial c'est l'organisation qui
doit être détruite pour que le grand
projet totalitaire de Poutine puisse
avoir lieu et mémorial c'est l'esprit de
solicine mémorial c'est l'esprit de
L'Archipel du Goulag et aujourd'hui
quand il y a un procès contre mémorial
quand il y a la dissolution de mémorial
en réalité ce qui se passe c'est quoi
c'est qu'on brûle l'archipel je peux
ajouter un mot on brûle l'archipel c'est
une phrase de mcine don il dit
l'archipel du GLaG c'est un monument au
mort et je crois que ça résume très bien
ça reprend ce que dit Raphaël alors ce
que ce qu'il faut préciser peut-être
après avoir entendu
cette cette phrase hein de de rapaël
lucman c'est que memmorial était une une
organis une association de défense des
droits de l'Homme russes qui a été créée
à la toute fin des années 80 on était
sous l'air Gorbatchev à l'époque et elle
a été dissoute officiellement en Russie
ici c'était le 28 décembre 2021 par
Vladimir Poutine voilà pourquoi
R de cette sorte qu'est-ce que vous avez
à dire sur cette rencontre avec le le
fils d'André gulzman bah c'était assez
saisissant parce que Raphaël Luxman
évoque sa jeunesse il a il a lu
l'archipel quand il était adolescent
mais il raconte qu'il a été bercé quand
même d'une certaine façon on lui a pas
lu le charpon rouge
mais vraiment et et donc
il il a bien insisté sur le fait que
c'était un héritage pour lui et et
vraiment je crois que c'était très
important et il l'a vécu comme tel et
euh et voilà c'était assez fort ces
mots-l parce que bon déjà on retrouvait
quelque part quand même son père mais
vraiment il
a garder cet héritage là de ce combat là
mais auourd'hui il y a un côté
révélation
une révélation au sens à la fois
religieux du terme et et scientifique du
terme à la fois historique et toute la
la vision qu'on pouvait avoir du
communisme malgré tout on trouvait des
raisons voilà mais c'est une révélation
et d'un seul coup tout sé clair et dit
je sais que ça été difficile pour cette
génération qui a cru plus que tout
autre si je peux l si je peux lire trois
lignes de ce liine pour expliquer tout
ça Alley le le jour où il a été expulsé
d'Urs en 74 solinitin a a publié un
texte voilà ce qu'il dit quand la
violence fait irruption dans la vie
paisible des hommes son visage flamboie
d'arrogance elle portait frontément
inscrit sur son drapeau elle crie je
suis la violence place écartez-vous où
je vous écrase mais la violence vieillit
vite encore quelques années et elle perd
son assurance et pour se maintenir pour
faire bonne figure elle recherche
obligatoirement l'alliance du M
car la violence ne peut s'abriter
derrière rien d'autre que le mensonge et
le mensonge ne peut se maintenir que par
la violence et je crois que ça c'est
vraiment le cœur de son travail il a
fait vous citez ce J si vous citez ces
phrases de ce jicde c'est au moment où
il est expulsé de son pays le jour même
où il est expulsé il som en 73 en 74
ouis en 74 autant pour moi c'est parce
que vous considérez que ces propos
peuvent encore avoir une résonance
aujourd'hui par rapport à ce
régime je l' cite mais bien sûr mais
bien sûr le secret plus plus il y aura
de secret plus la terreur pourra
s'instaurer bon moins il y aura de
secret mais le fait de liquider mémorial
ou en tout cas de tout faire pour
liquider mémorial parce que les gens de
mémorial continuent de se battre mais le
fait de tout faire pour liquider
mémorial c'est évidemment pour essayer
de maintenir un secret sur la terreur
qui est en train de monter en Russie
avec Monsieur Poutine à cause de cette
guerre en Ukraine qu'il a lui-même
déclenché et donc d'ailleurs il ne sait
pas comment se sortir ça il faut bien
dire alors ce lien avec cette
actualisation vous l'avez très bien
symbolisé à la toute fin du documentaire
avec ce caliddoscope hein où on voit les
les victimeses les Z hein ceux qui é
déporté dans les goulagues et puis ce
calédoscope se transforme avec les
personnes qui sont aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui même tout à fait toutes les
photos qu'on voit effectivement sur
ceimage sont des photos qu'on peut voir
sur sur le site mémorial de gens qui
sont actuellement détenus le le le mur
de des photos noir et blancs d'identité
judiciaire on l'avait eu au musée du KGB
à Vinus et et vraiment je je me suis dit
c'est c'est c'est frappant un peu C et
juste un mot quand même à la fin j'ai
découvert ce jeune youtubeur russe Yuy
douud qui a fait ce ce film incroyable
qui qui qui est encore visible sur sa
chaîne Youtube Colima lieu de naissance
de notre peur un film de 2 heures où il
est et ça c'est la jeune génération où
il est revenu sur les lieux 28 millions
de vues à ce jour sur ce film il a été
obligé de quitter la Russie parce que il
est aujourd'hui considéré comme un agent
de l'étranger on l'a eu au téléphone
enfin et et on lui a demandé
l'autorisation de de de de prendre un
extrait de son film et ça je trouve
c'est vraiment important parce que ça
c'est c'est c'est c'est la nouvelle
c'est la jeune génération donc tout ça
ne disparaît pas avec la mémoire des
gens qui l'ont connu et donc je je pense
que c'était important de le rappeler à
la fin de ce film parce que c'est du
coup ça donne un écho avec aujourd'hui
qui on commémore les les 50 ans de la
publication de ce
livre d'abord en russe hein céit à la
fin de toute fin de 73 et puis ensuite
en français au printemps 74
50 ans après si vous avez un édito à
commettre on sera sans doute pas les
seul à à commémorer cet événement qui
qui était la sortie de l'archipel du
goulac ça serao pour dire quoi oui c'est
le le livre qui a changé le communisme
il a une résonance aussi
à le secret du communisme il a une
résonance aujourd'hui alors peut-être
moins mais le le travail a été fait si
j'ose dire c'est par ce que fait Stéphan
Nicolas vert et cetera en fait ce
travail a été fait en partie évidemment
grâce à à ceine il a entreouvert une
porte
ces portes ce sont les portes des
archives parce que sans les archives
finalement voilà la preuve quelle est la
preuve de ce que vous avancez les
preuves existent voilà les preuves exist
les preuves du totalitarisme existe et
on va rappeler à quel moment on éta
ouvertes ces archives et à quel moment
vous avez vous même consulté à
Mos il y a aucun historien qui a imaginé
en en juin 198
que en janvier 92 les archives
s'ouvriraient ça ça ça paraissait
insensé mais totalement insensé hein et
soudain l'URS implose c'està-dire le
régime implose et l'URS explose
c'està-dire il y a 15 républiques qui se
créent et cetera et d'un seul coup on
arrive à Moscou et et heureusement les
archives ce qui est extraordinaire c'est
que en urs il n'y avait pas de loi sur
les archives les archives étaient sous
le contrôle absolu du comité central et
d'un seul coup il y avait plus de comité
central donc on a mangé notre pain blanc
pendant de ou 3 ans en disant aux
archivistes russes et ben ça y est vous
êtes démocrate faites comme nous ouvrez
puis alors après bon ça s'est refermé
hein petit à petit mais bon on a quand
même pu profiter pendant plusieurs
années de d'une grande ouverture et puis
le relais a été pris complètement alors
par les gens de mémorial qui et puis
publier à votre tour le livre noir du du
du
communisme qui lui aussi hein a provoqué
beaucoup de remou sa sortie hein vous
souvenez ou là là bon donc donc et c'est
tout à fait c'est tout à fait étonnant
de voir que l'histoire se répète elle
bégille d'une certaine manière
c'est-à-dire que les polémiques qu'il y
a eu pour la sortie de l'archipel du
goulac se sont reproduites au moment de
la sortie du Livre noir du communisme et
et et pour un peu elle se reproduirait
aujourd'hui à propos de Monsieur Poutine
bon ouis mais les choses ont avancé quoi
alors Dieu merci les choses ont avancé
mais le travail n'est jamais terminé on
est continuellement obligé quand vous
écoutez quand vous écoutez les
propagandistes russes aujourd'hui oui
faut écouter la
télévisiont jamais vu les archives ah
ben non c'est pas ça c'est qu'ils
veulent surtout pas les voir c'est autre
chose ça s'appelle le déni bon ça sera
le mot de la fin un grand merci vraiment
à tous les trois d'avoir participé à ce
débat après ce documentaire qui était un
un dument euh un documentaire exclusif
pour notre chaîne LCP L'Archipel du
Goulag le courage de la vérité merci
pour ce film j'encrais pu on était très
fier de pouvoir le présenter dans dans
cette émission vos réactions ça sera sur
hashtag desbadoc j'imagine qu'elles
seront assez nombreuses à la suite de
cette émission merci aussi à Selma S qui
m'a aidé comme elle accoutumé à
présenter cette émission et je vous
donne tout simplement rendez-vous pour
un prochain lbadoc et ça sera bien
entendu avec son documentaire et son
débat à
[Musique]
bientôt